[Musique]
bonjour et bienvenue à tous dans cette
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires voici tout de suite les
titres de l'actualité pour commencer ce
journal les équipes de via occitan ont
pu assister à une opération coup de
point des forces de l'ordre dans un
quartier sensible de nîes une opération
destinée à répondre au sentiment
d'insécurité dans un instant dans ce
journal à valenol ce sont les
producteurs de Lavand qui sont en crise
et n'ont pas d'autre choix vous allez
voir que de brûler leurs PL c'est ce
qu'a constaté notre partenaire sur place
de la Provence et puis si vous aimez les
animaux ce reportage est absolument à
regarder bien loin de la traditionnelle
image du loup Oracle et Mey ont un
regard profond et attachant une équipe
de TVR arène à rencontrer ses deux
chiens loups champions du monde et puis
en fin de journal l'histoire est
incroyable une partie du trésor
découvert par un alpiniste sur un
glacier du Mont-Blanc en 2013 a été
vendu aux enchères
Montblanc a suivi cette vente pas comme
les
autres bien sûr nous ne pouvions pas
débuter ce journal sans revenir sur
cette attaque terroriste qui a fait un
mort et trois blessés dans un lycée
d'aras dans le Pas de Calais vendredi
dernier 3 jours avant la commémoration
de la mort de Samuel paatti enseignant
assassiné par un terroriste déjà en 2020
DOM Bernard professeur de français est
mort poignardé et partout dans les
écoles de France une minute de silence a
été observée en hommage aux deux
enseignants c'est difficile c'est
difficile de voir ce toute cette
situation toutes ces horreurs c'est
difficile de pas être en colère mais en
même temps on a envie d'être empathique
et tolérant et on a envie d'aimer les
gens et de soutenir les
familles soutenir le métier aussi de
professeur mathtis mon plus grand de 13
ans euh
elle me dit il était à 10 cm du tueur et
il a vu le corps du prof par terre
devant lui et il a eu le réflexe de
partir en courant et de se réfugier chez
son copain un professeur assassiné tout
simplement parce qu'il est
professeur il est professeur il enseigne
il est là pour éduquer ses enfants c'est
quand même assez émouvant que la
République soit touchée dans son
enceinte scolaire et pour l'éducation
tout ça puis je trouve que c'est
important moi actuellement je suis
étudiante c'est important de venir bah
déjà puisque c'est un prof puis aussi
parce que c'est la France qui a été
touchée par cet
événement anime le quartier pisevin
avait été le théâtre d'échange de coups
de feu meurtrier durant l'été dernier
alors en attendant l'ouverture prochaine
d'un commissariat environ 120 policiers
CRS et gendarme mobile spécialisés dans
la recherche d'armes et de stupéfiants
ont procédé à de multiples contrôle sous
le regard rassuré de la population c'est
un reportage d'Olivier Michel pour via
Occitanie
est-ce que Chéry tu veux qu'on fasse
déjà de visu ouis de contrôle de
stupéfiant contrôle routier ou dans les
bus c'est une opération coup de point et
coordonnée à laquelle a été convié la
presse sur le quartier de Pissevin avec
une volonté affichée montrer la présence
de l'État sur le terrain l'idée
d'aujourd'hui c'est de marquer par une
présence massive d'effectif sur le
quartier d'avoir une opération je dirais
où on vient ensérrer la totalité du
quartier pour contrôler rechercher au
sein de l'ensemble des lieux qui sont
compris dans ce dans ce périmètre c'est
pour ça qu'on a un déploiement de ce
type de près de 120 effectifs qui est un
déploiement
massif au sein du quartier sur cette
opération d'harcèlement de point c'est
ce type d'opération qui nous a permis de
découvrir au sein d'un d'un box dans un
sous-sol qu armes de guerre 5 kg de de
résine de cannabis une présence
policière qui rassure la population peut
àide de
commentair si la police là c'est bien si
la gendarmerie vient là c'est bon par ça
là on dort bien on dort très bien c'est
c'est une opération coup de point qui
qui bon ça ça va pour les statistiques
de la police c'est bien mais mais le
problème c'est pas ça ce qu'il faut
faire il le savent vraiment en vérité la
drogue vient d' la drogue VI du
Maroc du Maroc coup les points avec le
Maroc Mo il y aura plus de drogue
annoncé en a dernier par géralde daranin
comme un sybole de reconquête
l'ouverture d'un poste de police mixte
et provisoire dans le quartier doit
intervenir avant la fin de l'année sans
transition je vous propose de nous
rendre dans les Alpes de HauteProvence
face à un marché qui s'est effondré
celui des producteurs de lavande du
plateau de valenol qui n'ont pas d'autre
choix que de brûler leur production
regardez ce reportage d'Eric camoi pour
notre partenaire de la Provence sur
place c'est triste les paysages sont
carrément différents vous pouvez voir
autour de vous c'était une parcelle de
20 haar maintenant il y a un chô de blé
des lavandes arraché je vais faire du SE
1 FO sans doute parce que le céréal le
coût de production est aussi élevé je ne
sais pas je ne sais pas où on
va pour moi c'est une culture endémique
de la région PACA du coup quand il y a
d'autres départements de France qui se
mettent en produire
c'est ça nous coupe l'herbe sous le pied
quoi on peut nous ce qu'on valorise
c'est notre terroir la la Vand est
typique notre terroir les touristes
viennent pour ça vous voyez des nuages
de touristes l'été c'est pour voir la
beauté de nos paysages ben là on aura un
paysage à ride et sec pas l'Espagne mais
mais presque quoi les lavandes vous en
verrez parsé mais plus c'est Mar marée
violette dans les vuges l'entreprise
fertile innve depuis 60 ans afin de
limiter l'usage du plastique en
développant des pots de fleurs
biodégradables dont 80 % sont destinés
au marché étranger en créant la marque
sans culotte le fabricant espère
maintenant convaincre le marché français
vous voyez ce reportage d'Aurélie
Colombel et d'élèine le plat pour vuge
télévision
ici la guerre contre le plastique est
ouverte 300 millions de PET sortent
chaque année de l'usine fertile basée à
le syndicat des récipients fabriqués
avec ses résineux venus du Grand est une
histoire qui a aujourd'hui 60 ans à
l'époque tout était fait à la main quand
un ingénieur trouve une solution
mécanique il fallait transformer une
cartonnerie qui faisait que du carton
pour les chaussures et qui était voué à
la disparition donc mon patron avait été
taacé pour justement commencer à
réfléchir à une une automatisation d'un
mouvement qu'on faisait donc pour former
les premiers godet la spécificité du
fertile peau c'est le fait de laisser
passer les racines de ne pas pouvoir de
ne pas devoir dépoter ensuite de le
mettre en terre directement il est
totalement biodégradable depuis 10 ans
les investissements se sont succédés
pour augmenter les capacités qui
pourrait selon les dirigeants être
encore multiplié par 3 l'entreprise
emploie désormais 60 personnes et dégage
10 10 millions de chiffres d'affaires 80
% de la production part à l'étranger
alors pour percer davantage le marché
français une nouvelle marque vient
d'être créé s culottes fait évidemment
appel à l'histoire française donc
révolutionnaire fait la révolution dans
le jardin d'une part et la plante s kil
c'est la plante sans déchet même si les
tarifs ne dépassent guerre quelques
centimes ils sont toutefois deux fois
plus chers que leur homologue en
plastique pour faire son trou le godet
en papier cartonné aurait besoin d'un
coup de pouce on a réussi à supprimer
les paill les cons de tiges en plastique
la vaisselle en plastique nous ce qu'on
veut maintenant c'est arriver à
supprimer les pot de fleurs en plastique
c'est possible on a une solution qui
marche et donc ce que l'on veut c'est
sensibiliser le gouvernement depuis 10
ans le secteur d'activité qui décarbone
le plus c'est l'industrie dont les
investissements se multiplient en ce
sens fertile par exemple a améliorer ses
emballages pour chasser le plastique et
installera prochainement une machine
pour rendre les peaux plus résistant à
l'humidité tout comme les montagnards
les jardiniers ont besoin dans les
potagers d'être bien chaussé depuis 1908
le fabricant des chaussures parabout
produit après 150 opérations manuelles
et 6 semaines de travail des chaussures
de très haute qualité connues pour leur
résistance Mirko prei nous emmène à la
découverte de ce savoirfire centenaire
pour téléGrenoble
regardez depuis 1908 la société Richard
pontvert fabrique des chaussures les
paraboutes cette entreprise familiale
est née à ISO là où a grandi Ry Richard
fondateur de l'entreprise Remy Richard
qui est un fils de d'agriculteur décide
juste après la Première Guerre mondiale
par aux États-Unis et il découvre
l'utilisation de de du caoutchou pour
protéger les les semelles qui à l'époque
étaient principalement des semelles en
cuir ou des semelles en bois il décide
donc de fabriquer des semelle en
caoutchou ce qui fait rapidement la
renommée de parabout au fil du temps
l'entreprise a à créer des chaussures
bah pour les pilotes d'essaiis du
Concorde ça pu être des chaussures pour
des explorateurs comme paulemy Victor
pour des expéditions en 1980
l'entreprise est en faillite mais la
mode change et le modèle michaell est
plébicité la société se relève et se
concentre désormais sur les chaussures
de ville aujourd'hui la marque iseroise
garde la même recette elle se veut être
garante du fabriqué en France 77% de
leurs matièr premières proviennent
d'entreprise française on travaille nous
avec des cuirs qui sont à la base des
cuirs de veau qui ont l'avantage d'être
les cuirs un petit peu les plus les plus
jolis là par exemple vous avez ce ce
cuir là qui est le cuir qu'on utilise
sur tous nos produits un peu iconiques
c'est un cuir qu'on utilise chez parabou
depuis plus de 80 ans les semelle en
caoutchou l'ADN de la marque sont cuites
à la manière d'un gaufrier cousu sur la
chaussure elles sont facilement
réparables mais ce savoir-faire
traditionnel doit s'adapter à son époque
parabot depuis les 100 dernières années
à toujours su innové grâce à
l'utilisation et la la remise en
question de ces matières premières
s'adapter aux nouvelles normes qui
évoluent tous les ans toujours essayer
de répondre aux attentes du client des
modèles plus souples des modèles qui
durent toujours plus longtemps qui sont
plus ressemelable aussi et qui
permettent aussi ben de s'adapter aux
besoins tels que des matières plus
naturelles plus végétales en en prenant
soin ces modèles peuvent atteindre 20
ans d'espérance de vie déplacé à
Saint-Jean de moirant 2017 l'entreprise
réalise la moitié de son chiffre
d'affaires à
l'étranger voilà beaucoup d'entre nous
ont été confrontés au refus de nos
enfants de déjeuner à la cantine le plus
souvent par crâne de subir les menus
proposés alors afin de rendre ce moment
plus convivial les élèves de cette école
primaire de laciota ont goûté et validé
pour tous leurs camarades C recettes
proposées par Sylvain chevalier
responsable de l'innovation culinaire du
groupe or regardez cette
interview 70 % des enfants qui vont
répondre ok la recette sera validée et
distribuée sur l'intégralité de nos
sites en France j'ai aimé le
hmous j'ai aimé la peine à la tomate
sauf qu'il manqu un peu de sel etit trop
chaud j'ai pas trop aimé
la la Bran dalle de Colin c'est ce que
tu as préféré goûter aujourd'hui ou
pas offrir le meilleur du territoire
dans la gastronomie de l'Aube c'est le
Paris réussi de ce fromager qui a
inventé le trifoir une spécialité
gastronomique issue de deux produits
locaux renommés le chatours et la
prunelle de tris cette création a
décroché une médaille d'argent au
Mondial du fromage en septembre victime
de son succès est déjà en rupture de
stock notre partenaire Canal 32 a réussi
à le goûter regarde
voici le trifoire un fromage de chaours
badigeonné à la prunelle de TR un combo
gagnant 100 % locale la liqueur est
coupée à 50 % avec de l'eau pour garder
le bon équilibre si on l'utilise pur on
va tuer le pénicilium du fromage donc
toute la croûte blanche et le fromage va
prendre énormément de puissance mais la
croûte va devenir grise donc un aspect
visuel pas très agréable et un goût de
trop fort ça change foncièrement le goût
du chaours par contre la prunelle le
goût d'alcool de prunelle ne domine pas
donc c'est tout en tout en finesse tout
en discrétion une fois la recette
réalisée tout réside dans l'affinage il
faut ensuite suivre l'évolution du
fromage et le développement de sa cûte
après le fromage est mis en chambre
froide évidemment sur des pailles de
segle il est couvert pour empêcher qu'il
sèche au contact du froid et puis au
bout de 12 jours on le réemballe et il
est bon à consommer résultat un fromage
au goût sucré pour le savourer mieux
vaut le sortir 2 he avant pour qu'il
soit à température ambiante un produit
artisanal qui peut facilement s'accorder
c'est un fromage qui peut se déguster
très facilement avec de la prunelle
glacée ça c'est très bon il peut se
déguster également en croustillant en
feuille de brique avec un flambage à la
prunelle également et puis bah tout
simplement avec du champagne ce produit
purement local jusque dans son nom et
pour cause le trifoir c'est un petit
cours d'eau qui prend sa source à
Saint-Germain et se jette dans la scène
à Saint-Julien les villas un produit
mûement réfléchi donc ériic l'élabore
depuis le mois de juin et le travail à
payer car s'il n'en fait pas tout un
fromage deux de ses créations le trifoir
et le Monon un petit mournier affiné au
Mar de raisin du Jura ont été récompensé
au Mondial du fromage à tour le 10
septembre dernier les deux ont été
primés par une médaille d'argent
donc je dois dire que le trifoir a a
échoué à 2,7 points de la médaille d'or
c'est une belle expérience une belle
réussite pour promouvoir le produit
cette nouveauté est déjà adoptée par la
clientèle comptez 7,50 € pour vous
procurer le trifoir s'il est pour leur
uniquement commercialisé à la fromagerie
de sain saavine Eric espère diffuser son
produit sur tout le département d'ici
quelques
mois voilà pour ceux qui aiment les
animaux ce reportage est pour vous à
l'opposé de l'imaginaire des enfants ils
sont plutôt craintifs mais affectueux
présenté au au dernier World Dog Show
Oracle et Mey ont été désignés plus beau
chien loup du monde Natacha Astor les a
rencontré pour TVR à reen
regardez alors ça c'est Mikey un chien l
SLOS de 6 ans il est brun forêt et bon
voilà c'est un chien qui fait des des
concours depuis tout petit plus beau
chien loup Sarlos du monde mais devant
les caméras Mikey et Oracle font un peu
les timides
va pas
venir allez viens Oracle pelage Grillou
a conquis le jury et remporte la plus
haute récompense du monde en devenant
meilleure femelle du concours face à 28
concurrentes c'est un petit peu réservé
de l'humain souvent il recule bon elle
elle est assez habitude donc elle recule
plus du tout devant les juges elle fait
même des câlins donc pour ça qu'elle
gagne c'est un peu pour ça elle charme
les juges cette passion des canidés
Orlan la tient de sa maman Vanessa qui
adopte son premier chien loup il y a
quelques années toutes les deux ont
habitué Mikey et Oracle à des bains de
foule et elle ne passe jamais inaperçu
soit les gens viennent vers nous pour
essayer de le caresser soit ils ont un
recul direct les gens connaissent
maintenant le chien loup de Sarlos c'est
très intéressant et puis c'est au moins
on sait qu'on qu'on sert à quelque chose
aussi quoi à faire connaître la race
timide peu sportif très observateur le
Chien Loup est une race bien
particulière qui demande de vraies
connaissances c'est pas les chiens pour
tout le monde ça demande beaucoup de de
temps beaucoup de bah d'implication de
connaissance aussi dans la race et dans
les dans le chien tout simplement les
deux éleveuses de Pléchâtel espèrent une
portée de petit chien loup dans l'année
à
venir malgré l'arrivée de l'automne
octobre h rose notre partenaire 20
minutes TV a rencontré loloïse Catherine
vilmine Lisa et Yael qui ont tout un
point commun avoir eu un cancer du sein
alors surmonter cette épreuve exige un
moral à toute épreuve qui passe par la
préservation de l'estime de soi malgré
les conséquences visibles des
traitements à Paris l'association belle
et bien propose des ateliers
pédagogiques afin de retrouver sa
féminité face à la maladie il y a une
partie soin et une partie makeup mais
vous allez voir qu'on va plus parler
d'effets pour le make-up on va pas être
sur un cours de maquillage he plus on
parlera d'un effet bonne mine on va
aller se positionner en faire en faisant
un tro sur le visage qui permet de
sculpter en fait le visage euh de donner
bonne mine
ouvrons maintenant une page culture et
patrimoine avec cette histoire
totalement extraordinaire digne
d'Indiana Jones plusieurs dizaines de
pierres précieuses découvertes il y a
près de 10 ans par un alpiniste dans les
débris d'un avion écrasé en 1966 dans le
Mont-Blanc viennent d'être vendu pour
notre partenaire 8 Mont-Blanc lucarou a
assisté à chambéie à cette vente aux
enchères pas tout à fait comme les
autres vous allez
voir voici une partie du butin de celui
que l'on surnomme le trésor des Bossons
ces nombreuses pierres précieuses ont
été découvertes il y a 10 ans par un
rang d'honneur parmi les débris d'un
crche d'avion survenu en 1966 dans le
massif du Montblanc si cette histoire
semble sorti d'un album des aventures de
Tintin elle est bien réelle en témoigne
ces nombreuses pierres précieuses ce
sont des lots assez hétéroclite hein
classé entre émeraude saphir la jadéide
se trouve
ici on a à la fois certains gros
calibres qui sont vendus à l'unité
souhaitant garder l'anonymat le
randonneur au savoyard ayant découvert
ce précieux trésor a aujourd'hui décidé
de s'en séparer grâce à une mise aux
enchères organisée à l'Hôtel Des vente
de Chambéry bijoutier passionné au
simple habitant de la région de nombreux
curieux ont fait le déplacement pour
espérer s'arracher l'un des 40 lot mis
en vente moi je j'achète et je revends
des pierres
précieuses donc ici on peut peut-être
trouver des belles opportunité il y a
quand même de belles pierres c'est des
pierres qui ont une histoire aussi
puisque c'est quand même un crche
d'avion outre leur valeur marchande ces
pierres précieuses ont évidemment aussi
une grande valeur historique
l'extraordinaire récit ponctué encore
aujourd'hui de nombreux mystères
participe à la renommée de ce fabuleux
trésor c'est extrêmement rare d'avoir
aux enchères un déc un trésor découvert
dans les
glaces la glace souvent broie beaucoup
de choses elle casse tout les épaves
reviennent déchiqueté là c'est des
pierres qui ont survécu survécu un crash
du feu sûrement les bijoux d'habitude ça
fond là c'est pas le cas il y a pas eu
de survivant malheureusement et ça
miraculeusement c'est dans une boîte en
métal qui n'a pas souffert c'est la
première fois de ma carrière que j'ai un
trésor comme ça à vendre dans des
circonstances aussi exceptionnelles
c'est aux alentours de 15h30 que débute
la mise aux enchères et certains
semblent bien décidés à repartir avec
leur propres morceau du
Trésor j'ai00 madame mis à prix entre 20
et 500 € certains lots se sont vendus
jusqu'à 2000 € pièces et si chacune de
ces pierres a aujourd'hui trouvé preneur
la seconde partie du trésor est toujours
visible au musée des cristaux de chamoni
proche de là où elles ont été
retrouvées voilà et à Toulouse c'est un
poème manuscrit écrit par Jacques
Prévert pour le décès de son ami Boris
Vian qui a été mis lui aussi aux
enchères ce poème manuscrit témoigne de
l'amitié et du lien indéfectible qui lié
ces deux hommes artiste à la très forte
sensibilité le poème composé par Jacques
Prévert est adressé à C Vian Kubler
seconde épouse de Boris Vian au décès de
ce dernier en
1959 ça reste quand même deux grands
monstres de la littérature française
donc forcément c'est des témoignages qui
sont voilà assz inédit et assez rares en
fait on sent l'amitié on sent la
fragilité de l'intellectuel et c'est
vraiment voilà c'est vraiment de un très
poignant hommage voilà la lettre de
Jacques Prévert a finalement été adjugée
pour tr 50 € à un collectionneur amateur
lui de Boris Vian saviez-vous qu'au
moyen-âge les Yvelines tout comme les
irréductibles Gaulois avaient vu passer
les Vikings le temps d'un weekend les
hommes d'Harald premers étaient mis à
l'honneur au château de la Madeleine la
reconstitution historique d'un campement
Viking du 9e siècle a attiré pas moins
de 10000 visiteurs un reportage de Louis
Douchin et de Régine ralèche pour tv78
sur
place
et ici au pied du château de la
Madeleine on vous forme à l'art de la
guerre Viking pendant 2 jours une
reconstitution historique a permis aux
10000 visiteurs présents de découvrir
leur mode de vie au 9e siècle les
Vikings sont passés dans les evelines il
y avait plusieurs camp Vikings qui
étaient sur les îles des bordde scèes
lorsqu'ils ont attaqué Paris au 9e
siècle donc c'est bien antérieur à la
période du château de la Madeleine mais
c'est une thématique qui est assez
porteuse qui plaît à beaucoup c'est
hyper important parce que bah du coup ça
représente aussi l'histoire comprendre
ai comment on vivait à l'époqueon est a
dans une génération aujourd'hui où les
enfants n'ont pas forcément notion de
tout ce qui est quotidien donc c'est
aussi important de de transmettre au
jeunes génération une autre époque et
une autre vie dans ce campement plus
vrai que nature une vingtaine de
bénévoles incarné la vie du camp ils
étaient présents afin de montrer le
savoir-faire des Scandinaves au
ivelinois chacun on leur particularité
donc de base nous représentons B la vie
en général donc la vie de camp selon les
envies capité de chacun choisissent de
faire soit de représenter le
combat ce qui faisait partie de leur vie
aussi et et des artisanats cette
association marli portaine le clan Divar
s'appuie sur des recherches historiques
pour proposer une expérience immersive
notre souhait c'était de faire de la
médiation culturelle autour de l'époque
doncour du peuple scandinave de l'air
Viking c'est extrêmement important
puisque c'est l'occasion pour nous de
mettre en valeur notre patrimoine de
l'ouvrir au plus grand nombre et de
proposer des animations qui peuvent
toucher tous nos publics le château de
la Madeleine proposera une nouvelle
programmation avec d'autres
consonstitutions historiques sur des
weekends dans les prochains mois les
dates ne sont pas encore
communiquées avant de nous quitter je
vous propose de découvrir le nouveau
show mise en lumière dans la cathédrale
Saint-André de Bordeaux luminiscence
c'est son nom transporte le spectateur
au temps des grands bâtisseurs du 12e
siècle une poesse technique destinée à
recueillir les fonds pour rénover le
grand org de la cathédrale Alix Fourcade
a eu la chance d'assister aux
répétitions pour notre partenaire TV7 du
groupe
[Musique]
sud-ouest c'est avec délicatesse que les
traits de la cathédrale Saint-André se
dessinent sous nos yeux d'abord on va
commencer par un parcours imersif dans
le déambulatoire pour découvrir les SEP
chapelles de la cathédrale mise en
lumière puis le public va s'asseoir dans
la nef et là le spectacle est articulé
autour de trois actes un premier sur
l'architecture et la construction de la
cathédrale il y a plus de 1000 ans près
de 1000 ans pour être exact deuxièmement
on va découvrir les vitrux et leur jeux
de lumière qui métamorphose la
cathédrale de l'aube au crépuscule et le
trè acte c'est autour de la musique à
travers les époques donc du Moyen-Âge au
barocque jusqu'à l'époque contemporaine
un spectacle de mapping de 35 minutes
résultat de 6 mois de pr préparation en
amont pour l'entreprise luminiscence on
souhaite que que notre public puisse
apprendre quelque chose repartir de
spectacle en ayant appris sur l'histoire
et les secrets de cette cathédrale mais
effectivement avant tout cet édifice a
été fait pour élever dans une dimension
spirituelle et donc on on on a cherché à
susciter cette même émotion tel que nos
grands baptiseurs l'ont cherché à le
faire aussi il y a près de 1000 ans
maintenant l'animation sera diffusée
tous les soirs du mercredi au samedi
jusqu'au 17 décembre avec SEP soirée
exceptionnelle de musique live prévu
animé par le chef d'orchestre Alexis
Dufort vous allez entendre du foret vous
allez entendre du gounau du devvorjac du
Grig des grands classiques des pièces un
peu moins connues et tout ça va être
collé normalement si tout se passe bien
directement sur l'image le but c'est de
que les bordelés se réapproprient leur
cathédrale parce que on s'occupe du
cultuel mais il y a aussi le culturel et
que c'est un patrimoine vivant qu'on
doit faire vivre parce que si on le fait
pas personne le fera l'uminiscence a été
coconstruit avec l'association de
musique sacrée cathédra qui va récupérer
une partie des recettes pour rénover
l'orgue de la cathédrale un grand projet
dont le coût total est estimé à 3
millions d'euros voilà c'est la fin de
cette édition merci à vous de l'avoir
suivi on se retrouve très vite pour une
nouvelle édition du Grand JIT des
territoires au revoir à
[Musique]
tous